President Eisgruber, I have the honor
to present to you for the degree of
Doctor of Laws honoris causa our Barbara
cuteness teen this visionary leader is
the first woman woman to serve as
president of the College of New Jersey
in the institution's hundred and sixty
year history determined to provide her
students with the highest caliber
academic experience she has led
transformative efforts to improve TCN
J's four-year graduation rate which now
ranks among the highest in the nation
for public colleges and universities on
a national level she has been a
steadfast advocate for academic rigor
high standards and expanded educational
opportunity throughout her career as a
scholar of Jewish and American
literature and as an insightful
administrator she has demonstrated the
power of education to change the to
change lives and to change the world
al-tohra Tata mejia Cora Tori Basu near
Satara spring catonian says camisa de ad
gradum doctores in legatus honora's
causa admitto
you